bonsoir on se bourre sirène merci de
répondre à nos questions en direct sur
arte france une normalisation entre
européens et turcs ça pourra ressembler
à quoi car bruxelles dit ne pas vouloir
passer l'épongé sur les recherches du
c'est agressif de la turquie des
recherches d'hydrocarbures dans d autres
maritime revendiquée par athènes et
nicosie
bonsoir tout d'abord l'invitation à
président ali on installe un climat
beaucoup plus positif dans les premiers
jours 2021 on le maquis à unique au lieu
de normalisation avec apaisement des
relations de la turquie avec le mans qui
a commencé à la fois avec l'union
européenne la france et même les pays du
golfe avec lesquels on vous savez le
qatar beaucoup de problèmes en raison de
l'embargo qu'il avait pas imposé en 2010
fait avec l'union européenne et la
turquie et a eu beaucoup de beaucoup de
divergences d'intérêts par un beaucoup
de régions du monde comme la
méditerranée orientale
est ce que la turquie l'autre au chalut
leur quinze de mener une politique de la
carotte et du bâton et politique de deux
poids deux mesures et la turquie
voudrait vraiment que les européens
tient ses premiers singles la turquie
est cassé ce que mener cette politique
agressif et cette politique de deux
poids deux mesures a en l'air et la
turquie il ya eu beaucoup de décembre et
cette normalisation comme beaucoup j'ai
10 ans d'immigration de la turquie a
tendu un rameau d'olivier à tous les
pays avec lesquels elle avait tenu des
rubis tension au long de l'année 2020 et
elle a par exemple elle l a dit caroline
personnes avec l'union européenne avec
mam la france avec laquelle elle a vécu
beaucoup de tension que par exemple le
président duclos dietary paraguay et le
président français manuel maintenant ce
sont écrits et le président marc qu'on
lui envoyait des lettres qui commence
avec sharif en dessous donc le coup
monté pour tous le montrer sa volonté
d'apaiser les tensions nées d'ouvrir une
nouvelle page de construire un dialogue
avec cette turquie et tout ça c'est de
la france on sait que paris par exemple
a largement soutenu athènes dans ce
conflit méditerranéen en recherche
d'hydrocarbures
quelle est la marge de manoeuvre la
marge d'influencé française la marge
influence grecque également sur la
position de l'union européenne vis-à-vis
de la turquie selon vous la turquie a
proposé le lancement d'une conférence
internationale et cela met des terrains
nus remis en attaque pour l'avoir l'ong
help et constructif avec toutes les
parties
le problème c'est que les lieux le
requin ne reconnais pas réparé mal des
intérêts légitimes de la turquie et en
mai détient 90 alors que ce pays a le
plus long littoral en méditerranée
orientale donc ça pose un grand souci à
nous tiennent en compte que les intérêts
de la grèce et de chypre alors que la
turquie essaie de préserver ses intérêts
et mais aussi de ses intérêts défi de la
république turque de chypre du nord
donc cette conférence internationale et
sous la méditerranée orientale peut
aussi être bon état et il veut trouver
un compromis entre toutes les parties à
la fois la turquie et les pays européens
et comment ankara peut convaincre
l'union européenne quels sont ces
arguments c'est qu'il ya toujours la
question des migrants dans la balance
c'est toujours un moyen de pression de
la part d'ankara
alors il faut savoir que nature qui
attend au point de lui l europe 1 depuis
maintenant plus de 60 ans qu'on vous
savez elle a déposé sa demande
l'association de la communauté
économique européenne en 59 et qui est
devenu par la suite l'union européenne
elle a été reconnu officiellement
candidat sérieux ne repère dans 99 dont
40 ans plus tard et depuis cette date là
seulement ces chapitres de négociations
ont été ouverts sur 35 chapitres du coup
les relations avec l'ue qu'est l'amour
le père d avance très lentement et la
france s'oppose à l'adhésion de la
turquie à l'union européenne depuis le
début
avec par exemple le président de
l'ancien président de colo sarkozy qui
proposait un partenariat privilégié
plutôt qu'une adhésion à part entière et
donc pourquoi la turquie devrait adhérer
à l'ue ne repère mais il faut expliquer
ça parce que en fait son pays qui a
prouvé et se prouver ces militaires et
diplomatiques dans différents régions du
monde tout au long de l'année 2009 1
commandes à vue à la fois un syrie en
ligne et dans le hockey là bas est un
exemple notamment dans tous ces conflits
notamment notamment la libye on sait
qu'à eu également à l'opération
rameau d'olivier du côté du côté de la
syrie la turquie qui fait partie
également de l'otan justement demain
mais vous de cavusoglu rencontre le
secrétaire général de l'otan et jens
stoltenberg
puis à une rencontre aussi avec le
président du conseil européen charles
michel qu'est-ce qu'il faut attendre de
ces rendez vous et la turquie sont
impossibles à confirmer la prise en
compte en termes d'effectifs dans l'eau
tente donc du coup tout l'otan la
turquie a toujours été un levier très
important et le problème de malheureux
de l'otan c'est de l'eau pas réellement
comprendre les les préoccupations ses
petits dans sa lutte par exemple
antiterroriste qu'on vous savez la
turquie contre plusieurs groupes
terroristes comme le coca les grecs pg
dont le groupe eca en syrie et mais
aussi avec le délire la tentative ne
pouvons pas le bénisse et en turquie et
l'europe mais l'otan ne plus soutenir la
turquie dans sa lutte antiterroriste
mais aussi plus soutenir la turquie ont
dansé gestion des mines blanc parce
qu'actuellement les tours en plus + 2 et
3 7 millions de migrants et en dépensant
à peu près 40 milliards de dollars pour
bien accueillir c'est donc tous et tous
pour pousser de la turquie devait
plusieurs prises en compte à l'arrivée
leur plein de l'otan ou le meilleur
dialogue entre les parties et en
maintenant comme je vous salue en lui
une européenne devrait cesser cette
politique de deux poids deux mesures en
voir la turquie et avoir une politique
nous on est plus constructif envers la
turquie et on voit qu'en fait il est
l'organe a une approche très mal
gouverné depuis les débuts c'est à dire
donner des exemples dans les événements
de 2013 alors que nous allons condamner
ou on n'a jamais entendu
ces tapis olemps policière a parlé d'une
politique de deux poids deux mesures de
la part de l'union européenne mais il
n'y a pas eu aussi un petit peu de
provocation de la part de redjep tayyip
erdogan est bien évidemment s'il allait
aujourd'hui et monte le son qu'il ne
reviendrait les pays européens c'est
parce que justement dans ce sens un peu
honte aux noirs sirène la présidente
donc du site d'information rédaction
médias et donc spécialiste de la turquie